spin me around what's going on there go
up come on go I gotta get dizzy hey
everybody welcome back to the couch only
joined by my friend temor today because
we're playing WWE and Lucy said WWE is
fake wrestling is fake and she wants
nothing to do with it was devastating
I'm lying she's actually sick yep that's
the story of mistake you probably said
that stuff somebody said it something in
life we should preface this by saying
we're awful at WWE it turns out you've
played what one match is not a real
fighting game it's a it's very difficult
and I mean you're gonna see us play so
let's just get into it with your very
very bad okay so Tam and I are in a tag
team we have got tagged name we're doing
a tag team Hell in a Cell oh my god this
is my mocha photography so as much to
say we made our own characters we have
no idea which was made and towns can
look at that beautiful he's kind of like
an homage to point the clown and buggy
from one piece gurdas accepts not emerge
to anything except if he got like mauled
by a lion attacks and then covered in
grease shuts the front of mankind why
does he have hustle loyalty respect
tattooed at his back in like the
brightest tattoo of a serious about
causing a massive John Cena fan loyalty
respect you know that's just John Cena's
logos I know a dude on him he's a bit of
everything he's got a samurai shoulder
pads he's got like I don't know
steampunk goggles right the Hitman Hart
leggings he's also an angel okay yeah
that looks back make some pizza song
cool here I like is a greasy here he's
so greasy ah cool sick he's wearing like
four layers of shorts involved because
here but I made sure I said a bath in a
chip pan I just mind my character I put
effort into we're talking about love my
paranoid i put love into my character I
was loyal to loyalty it's just you Jesus
mean he's me game looks living me
looking oh my
did you use the face scanning to do this
you can import your face and it will
like put it over beer I've got a prize I
used it as well but I put my ass in
front of me can you input the picture of
your ass like pulling my cheeks apart i
was like import this and they put it
right on my characters face is that way
it's so greasy yep that's exactly why I
think I did a pretty good job my
daughter a lot like you i'm quite i wish
i wish i was that [ __ ] smaller
nothing going on there yeah I wish I'd
of Cape as well think about it i'd love
to see who's walking to work one day
like that this time to make videos go
ahead let's throw my k off all right
we'd only see the rest of it I do i do
kind of do a lap where were they what
what's that say on those shows yeah look
at that so we're we're fighting I
honestly can't look at my coach we'll
take what we call the juror before the
mustache menaces special i mean because
they both got those hits the most i ever
great my stashes who is this I haven't
seen rustling in a long time by the way
so all of this is baffling to me well I
i watch i watch wrestling every month
but it's like indy wrestling indian
restaurant Indian wrestling yeah all
right i'm in i watch her progress
wrestling every month right but that's
like just you know damn camden mm-hmm
the vaudevillians i mean we don't need
to watch this let's just let's just kick
the Reds in mmm you me mate you me yes
yes team look at on it was already like
what the hell is that one on the left
all about all right looks terrifying so
you're going to use the practice of the
one game you played yes there we go Oh
what those counter timings are brute
well yeah the counters are really
difficult oh my god they're like flash I
got you one second got you nice i'm
going focus on i will swapping yeah I'm
kick him in the yeah that's it there we
go again another elbow is erratic Elmo
to the heads I definitely have taken
some drugs before this look good look
out four C's moving now i do want to
brag on the ring hey oh you come in you
can poke me how do i do a dragon punch
was a quarter circle forward press
camera hammer
get up you know for a pimp because I
can't so hit him already you're trying
to end this as quick as possible haha
I'm even in the ring anymore get up you
chomp I just I just try to break his
fingers with some things some of the
moves that wrestlers do seem so like
pointless like when they just pick him
up and put him down again or like i'm at
mumbai by the finger and like rub the
skin really hard a big man i'm gonna
give you a blister and chucking you down
again it's gonna hurt like that what's
all about oh god kind of damage his
wrist i'm gonna destroy your wrist your
risk is not gonna f your wrist i like
the way the ref is just completely
forgot about what's going on inside the
ring it's cuz he's like this guy it's
just destroying his rest dad I can't get
these reversals some spin me around it's
going on there go up come on girl get
dizzy look at me i'm doing some sick
maneuvers man i'm get my ass kicked oh
my man is shabbos he's got so much
momentum aren't you can't just spam
watching this get back in the ring I'm
gonna need there we go just sprint into
the ring okay if your guy just like your
foe he's just staring you down I do this
not give that respect this
how do you go back in the room the
sprint holder holder oh my god I'm so
sorry wrap there you go I did it pick it
out I did it mom a wrestler now [ __ ]
every stop targets again yeah it's fine
okay okay okay I've got this guy's but
it pretty well got a new risk to work
with your week in his wrists are now
well I'm I'm get my ass kicked help me
alright switching switching is really
weird just-just-just younger one guy
killer English they go kick it down kick
him down oh they're right switch back
switch back just casually walked over
and place my fault his head oh no not
yet get out of RAM off my switch from
his wrist to his left buttocks oh no get
back yeah where's my guys doing how you
like that how you like dem apples naked
man speaking about my guy keeps climbing
up I did that let me write that again he
did that a schoolboy maneuver way put
his legs behind oh my days I just I'm
screwing this up so hard I trying to
climb the ref is blocking my popup
notifications he's the APB of there we
go as that's why I wanted to do I don't
know that I should not have taken that
long to pull off that move oh I'm get my
ass kicked again that's it other nothing
list well you can't deny it's been back
into the ring
no I'm going back into the ring hey like
these fists eat that all right elbows
you've exposed your wrist he's gonna
regret that there we go out you go again
what did that do that did nothing did
more damage to me than him I use his leg
as leverage to launched myself onto the
canvas right back up and you're going oh
beginning to the body don't you punks I
mean where you bought that mustache wax
oh there we go there we go what would
you say about my green here ah stairs
I'm gonna go for a pin don't go for a
pill i'm not busy staring this guy all
right i'll just pick another test a
bunch of fun Irish whip over here I
would have hit with some steel chairs
still chest got man I got a gift for you
bring like the ring Wow there you go
they go time grandpa other you just hit
me with it it's a gift use it he'll
throw the stairs out my face and then
tell me it's a gift it's a gift hey pick
it up it's a good time pick it up pick
it in let me begin by works with I was
hoping we could do some like Boing who
to Mammon Eve is there that did me I'm
not telling I'm nothing I'm just
exhausted me Halle Halle ok I got the 10
it's fine i switch targets and go i can
go for Dodge all right let's go hey
little guys
hayden we've been a bad Englishman
hitting with the stairs it's a l1 to
pick up the stuff what is happening to
me in that corner it's going on you need
to help me let's just switch they didn't
mean it is the hell that means and
emotions are so long you press one
button it's like sailing for Lord of the
Rings yes stop taunting oh god I don't
think I switch dammit time excuse me CZ
we do not that's my kids I am his
gesture have to look after him I got
moved though I don't let me help you out
let me get this guy away from you I
think I'm just stunned there we go there
we go Oh No saved your ass beautiful and
then you I didn't touch you you did you
clean my afro is disheveled my green
afro that's right will rub some greet
more grease in it you don't know just
from my arm to my hair we say we sure
you're talking a lot of smoke but what's
going on now hired hay like these X
buttons I'm gonna put my crush on you
hey like that like that we go submission
submission time yeah you gonna submit
submits the king submit to the gig so
that's the game i am your leash oh this
is so difficult bag oh wow today it's
guys flying back help me gosh you you
know the problem is the girls a halo of
my head i keep thinking is like o.o
maneuver a flippin jeep in stewie pin Oh
David 120 do you thing was enough
I know that one again where I do more
damage myself these guys must be dead
right now yeah how they still alive oh
so close get up you scum there we go
here we go don't get up yet don't get up
yet I'm doing my special move oh it was
a weight this makes my time how are you
use help me he's going to finish me it's
gonna hit me the finisher yeah excellent
work now the excellent work he landed a
finisher me all the same though it's
fine I took a risk you got your latest
raphy stay in there just all that
greece's this map is like a good king
well juggle my underwear throat shut
your mouth only dreams only dreams and
these are your pins again again yeah go
three different attempts ah I really
want my duty pin to work the lay of the
game get two extra feet playing as human
mess it's all right dad touch me so
greasy son of a [ __ ] hustle loyalty
respect okay you deserve it who are you
nice oh god I hate these clothes up so
much or considering with terrible this
game I think we did all right not bad
you're amazing everyone email Vince
McMahon and tell them you want to see
catastrophe live if that's a real
wrestler they're gonna have to go
through like surgery time yeah I don't
think anyone happy unless it's a
straight face raheel though what I set
him to be incredibly arrogant I'm you
like geezer heal my guys a face every
yeah he's got very low skill so he's
covering he's over compensating for his
inability to wrestle well I mean he did
it right here yeah do we debris well
it's like I really expected to lose and
have to try this again the end I think
it's cause he was in the presence of his
Lord and Master the king gave me like
gave him the existed he knew like if I
don't win this I executed all right well
I think we're both surprised that we
want ya if you enjoy that if you want to
see more videos like this one if you
enjoyed make sure you hit that like
button subscribe to gamespot fencing on
the map yeah why not catch you later